Continuing
[Silence]
in the narration of
Malik
the prophet sallallah.ai's
maternal uncle from his mother's side
in the chapter
of intentions and sincerity.
Now we reached in this narration
yesterday
to a point where
tells us that he fell ill during
and this was in the ninth year after hij
during the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's final and only so
first and only Hajj saiam
now sad made hijra from Mecca to Medina.
And it was not permissible
for anyone
after they had made hijra from Mecca to
Medina
to go back to Mecca,
even after it became a Muslim city, even
after it was even after it became
controlled by the Muslims. Why is that?
because it was something that was left
off for the sake of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam
prohibited his companions from going
back on a commitment that they had
already made.
And so S
fell very ill and he thought that he was
going to die. He thought that he was on
his deathbed at this moment in time. He
had a lot of money. He had a lot of
wealth. He was a very wealthy man. And
he only had one daughter.
And so he asked the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam about
meaning a will and testament. Now a will
and testament in Islam applies to what?
Applies to no more of a person's wealth
than onethird.
No matter how wealthy they are, whether
they have a hundred billion dollars or a
hundred dollars, it does not apply to
more than onethird
of their property, their assets, their
wealth at the time of their death. And
so
we learn from this that
was asking the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam. In my situation, I only
have one daughter.
Should I not give twothirds of it to the
poor, the Muslims, the masid, the
military, whatever it is, right? Not
necessarily just to poor people. Could
be to
for the for all of the Muslims to share
in it. And the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said, "No." He said, "How about
half?" He said, "No." He said, "How
about a third?" And the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam responded, "A
third is acceptable, but that's still a
lot." Meaning it's un it's not
preferable. It is acceptable, but not
preferable.
And so
before we continue with the remainder of
the narration,
I want you to take this narration into
to heart with regards to the
prophet Muhammad sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam's understanding
of the commands of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and are those commands specific to his
time are they specific to his
circumstances
or are those commands
commands by Allah for every place and
time
why do I say this so sad had one
daughter
she is his heir and his only heir. She
is going to inherit twothirds of all of
Sad Malik's wealth. That is a lot of
wealth for anyone.
But during the time
of the prophet and the companions,
that is a huge amount of wealth,
especially for a female, especially for
a woman.
Women are not men
and the potential
there for business. The potential for is
greater and more likely
with a son than it is with a daughter in
the time in this kind of situation. Not
not just in his time and any time. And
also because of the way that the rulings
of Islam are, if a woman is married,
then it it it has happened to where this
wealth now becomes open season for her
husband or anyone else to take advantage
of. It's more likely to be squandered,
less likely to be taken advantage of. in
the way that a businessman Sadi bin
Malik would have understood. And so the
principles
and the portions of inheritance are
already set out by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Correct? In
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala already
divided all of that up and he said that
a male
has two portions
that a female has.
A male has the same allotted to him as
two females. Now notice Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala didn't say a female has half
of what a male gets. It's the same
thing, right? A male gets two portions
of what a female gets. A female gets
half of what a male gets. Isn't that the
same thing? Right? Six of one and half
dozen of another. However, words matter
and the way that words are spoken
matter. The point here is that Sad
is essentially asking the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam at this point after
these have been revealed and after these
portions have been set that these
portions are set. However, do these
portions apply
to
can they only apply to onethird of my
assets? Can they apply to one half of my
assets? Can they apply to onethird of my
assets? And the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam
has stated even to Sad
even to Sad who only has one heir that's
going to get all this money and it's a
female
one-third. That's it. And the portions
of inheritance remain the same. Compare
that now to some modern philosophies
that are cropping up with some Muslims
and in some circles where they say,
"Well, you know what? Maybe we should
re-examine
the portions and the distribution of
inheritance." You know, times have
changed since the Quran was revealed.
And did Allah really intend for these
these portions
to be the same no matter what? I mean,
women aren't the same as men. They
aren't the same as they were back then.
And so, is this something specific to
time and place or is this general? Here
in this situation, which is considered
an extreme situation,
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
maintained
the portions and rules of inheritance
they applied to sad just they
applied to everyone else
and so this idea that we need to
modernize the Quran and play around with
what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down
to humanity and you know often times
this isn't out of necessity it's not out
of a a serious misunder understanding.
Usually this is just so that we can
appease people who are not of us and
appease a people who do not accept what
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent down.
And so
then said to the prophet Sam,
meaning
[Silence]
was
for
[Silence]
the
what has dad for
[Silence]
ayat. for
ache.
[Silence]
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells Sad he says to him, "Oh
messenger of Allah, am I going to be
left behind? My companions get their
reward for their full hij and here I
will pass away in Mecca having my reward
depleted for hijra." And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam made two
statements to him. The first he said if
you were to be left behind and if your
hijra were to be for the sake of
argument
worst case scenario were to be depleted
by
this illness and your death here in
Mecca.
Then keep in mind that in spite of that
you will not do any deed, any good deed
in which you seek the pleasure of Allah
in doing except that you will be raised
in stature and levels with Allah.
Meaning not all hope is lost because one
deed is incomplete. You continue to push
on. You continue to strive on until your
last breath leaves your chest, until the
last beat of your heart, until
the angel of death extracts your soul.
Then he says another statement to him.
He said, "And perhaps perhaps you will
be you will live on
beyond this illness that you're
currently in to the point where you will
where a multitude of people will be
benefited by your presence whilst others
harmed by your presence." speaking about
the Muslims and their enemies, that he
would lead the Muslims into combat
against their oppressors and that he
would be in a position of power to be
able to benefit the Muslims immensely by
his presence. This is considered one of
the prophe prophecies of our messenger
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam which will
continue to speak about tomorrow.
Alhamdulillah.